fellow americans good morning
certain dates echo throughout history
including dates that instantly remind
all who have lived through them
where they were
and what they were doing
when our democracy came under assault
dates that occupy
not only a place on our calendars
but a place
in our collective memory
december 7th 1941
september 11
2001
and january 6
2021
on that day
i was not only vice president-elect
i was also a united states senator
and i was here at the capitol that
morning at a classified hearing
with fellow members of the senate
intelligence committee
hours later
the gates of the capitol were breached
i had left
but my thoughts immediately turned
not only to my colleagues
but to my staff
who had been forced to seek refuge in
our office
converting filing cabinets
into barricades
what the extremists who roamed these
halls targeted
was not only the lives
of elected leaders
what they sought to degrade
and destroy
was not only a building
hallowed as it is
what they were assaulting
were the institutions
the values
the ideals
that generations of americans
have marched
picketed
and shed blood
to establish
and defend
on january 6
we all saw
what our nation would look like
if the forces who seek
to dismantle our democracy
are successful
the lawlessness
the violence
the chaos
what was at stake then
and now
is the right to have our future decided
the way the constitution
prescribes it
by we
the people
all the people
we cannot let our future be decided
by those bent
on silencing our voices
overturning our votes and peddling lies
and misinformation
by some radical faction
that may be newly resurgent
but whose roots
run old and deep
when i meet with young people they often
ask
about the state of our democracy about
january 6th
and what i tell them
is january 6
reflects
the dual nature
of democracy
its fragility
and its strength
you see the strength of
democracy is the rule of law
the strength of democracy
is the principle
that everyone should be treated equally
that elections
should be free and fair
that corruption
should be given no quarter
the strength of democracy
is that it empowers
the people
and the fragility of democracy is this
that if we are not vigilant
if we do not defend it
democracy simply will not stand
it will falter and fail
the violent assault that took place here
the very fact of how close we came
to an election
overturned
that reflects the fragility of democracy
yet
the resolve i saw in our elected leaders
when i returned to the senate chamber
that night
their resolve not to yield but to
certify the election
their loyalty
not to party or person
but to the constitution of the united
states
that
reflects its strength
and so of course does the heroism
of the capitol police
the d.c metropolitan police department
the national guard and other law
enforcement officers
who answered the call that day
including those
who later succumbed
to wounds
both visible
and invisible
our thoughts are with all of the
families who have lost a loved one
you know i wonder
how will january 6
come to be remembered
in the years ahead
will it be remembered as a moment
that accelerated the unraveling of the
oldest
greatest
democracy in the world
or
a moment
when we
decided to secure and strengthen our
democracy
for generations to come
the american spirit
is being tested
the answer to whether we will meet that
test
resides where it always has resided in
our country
with you
the people
and the work ahead will not be easy
here in this very building
a decision will be made
about whether we uphold the right to
vote
and ensure
free and fair elections
let's be clear
we must pass
voting rights bills that are now before
the senate
and
the american people
must also do something more
we cannot sit on the sidelines
we must unite
in defense
of our democracy
in order
to form a more perfect union
establish justice
ensure
domestic tranquility
provide for the common defense
promote
the general welfare
and secure
the blessings of liberty
to ourselves
and to our prosperity and posterity
that is the preamble of the constitution
that president biden and i swore an oath
to uphold and defend
and that is the enduring promise
of the united states of america
my fellow americans
it is my honor
to introduce a public servant
with the character and fortitude
to meet this moment
a leader whose life's work
has been moving our nation
toward that more perfect union
president joe biden
madam vice president
my fellow americans
state the obvious
one year ago today
in this sacred place
democracy was attacked
simply attacked
the will of the people was under assault
the constitution our constitution
faced
the gravest of threats
outnumbered in the face of the brutal
attack
the capitol police
the d.c metropolitan police department
the national guard
and other brave law enforcement
officials saved the rule of law
our democracy held
we the people endured
we the people prevailed
for the first time in our history
president had not just lost an election
he tried to prevent the peaceful
transfer of power
as a violent mob breached the capital
but they failed
they failed
on this day of remembrance we must make
sure that such attack never never
happens again
i'm speaking to you today from statuary
hall
in the united states
this is where the house of
representatives met for 50 years in the
decades leading up to the civil war
just on this floor
for a young congressman of illinois
abraham lincoln
sat at desk 191.
above him
above us
over that door
leading into the rotunda
is a sculpture
depicting cleo
the muse of history
in her hands
an open book
in which she records the events
taking place in this chamber below
cleo stood watch over this hall
one year ago today
as she has
for more than 200 years
she recorded what took place
the real history
the real facts the real truth
the facts and the truth that vice
president harris just shared
and that you and i
and the whole world saw with our own
eyes
the bible tells us that we shall know
the truth
and the truth shall make us free
we shall know the truth
well here is the god's truth
about january 6 20
21
close your eyes go back to that day
what do you see
riders rampaging
waving for the first time inside this
capital
confederate flag that symbolized the
cause to destroy
america
to rip us apart
even during the civil war that never
ever happened
but it happened here
in 2021
what else do you see
a mob
breaking windows
kicking in doors
breaching the capital american flags on
poles being used as weapons as spears
fire extinguishers being thrown at the
heads of police officers
a crowd that professes their love for
law enforcement assaulted those police
officers
dragged them sprayed them stomped on
them
over 140 police officers were injured
we all heard the police officers who
were there that day testified to what
happened
one officer called it quote
a mid
medieval battle
and that he was more afraid that day
than he was fighting the war in iraq
they've repeatedly asked since that day
how dare anyone
anyone
diminished belittle or deny the hell
they were put through
we saw with our own eyes
riders menace these halls
threatening the life of the speaker of
the house
literally erecting gallows to hang the
vice president of the united states of
america
what did we not see
we didn't see a former president
who had just rallied the mob to
attack sitting in the private dining
room off the oval office in the white
house
watching it all on television
and doing nothing
for hours
as police were assaulted
lives at risk
the nation's capital under siege
this wasn't a group of tourists
this was an armed
insurrection weren't looking to uphold
the will of the people they were looking
to deny the will of the people
they were looking to uphold they weren't
looking uphold a free and fair election
they were looking to overturn one
they were looking to save the cause of
america
they were looking to subvert the
constitution
this isn't about being bogged down in
the past
it's about making sure the past isn't
buried
that's the only way forward
that's what great nations do
they don't bury the truth
they face up to it sounds like hyperbole
but that's the truth they face up to it
we are a great nation
my fellow americans
in life there's truth
and tragically there are lies
lies conceived and spread
for profit
and power
we must be absolutely clear about what
is true
and what is a lie
and here's the truth
the former president of the united
states of america
has created and spread a web of lies
about the 2020 election
he's done so because he values power
over principle
because he sees his own interest
as more important than his country's
interest than america's interest
and because his bruised ego
matters more to him than our democracy
or our constitution
he can't accept he lost
even though that's what 93 united states
senators
his own attorney general
his own vice president
governors and state officials in every
battleground state
have all said he lost
that's what 81 million of you did as you
voted for a new way forward
he is not what no president
in american history the history of this
country has ever ever done he refused to
accept the results of an election
and the will of the american people
well some courageous men and women in
the republican party are standing
against it
trying to uphold the principle of that
party
too many others are transforming that
party into something else
they seem no longer to want to be the
party the party of lincoln
eisenhower reagan the bushes
but whatever my other disagreements are
with republicans who support the rule of
law and not the rule of a single man i
will always seek to work together with
them
to find shared solutions where possible
because if we have a shared belief in
democracy then anything is possible
anything
and so at this moment
we must decide
what kind of nation are we going to be
are we going to be a nation that accepts
political violence as a norm
are we going to be a nation will we
allow partisan election officials to
overturn
the legally expressed will of the people
are we going to be a nation that lives
not by the light of the truth
but in the shadow
of lies
we cannot allow ourselves to be that
kind of nation
the way forward is to recognize the
truth
and to live by it
the big lie being told by the former
president and many republicans who fear
his wrath
is that the insurrection in this country
actually took place on election day
november 3 3rd
2020. think about that
is that what you thought
is that what you thought when you voted
that day
taking part in an insurrection is that
what you thought you were doing
or did you think you were carrying out
your highest duty as a citizen and
voting
former president's supporters are trying
to rewrite history
they want you to see election day as the
day of insurrection
and the ride that took place here on
january 6th as a true expression
of the will of the people
can you think of a more twisted way to
look at this country to look at america
i cannot here's the truth
the election of 2020
was the greatest
demonstration of democracy in the
history of this country
more of you voted in that election than
have ever voted in all of american
history
over
150 million americans went to the polls
and voted that day
in a pandemic
somewhat grace great risk to their lives
they should be applauded
not attacked
right now
in state after state
new laws are being written
not to protect the vote
but to deny it
not only to suppress the vote but to
subvert it
not to strengthen and protect our
democracy
but because the former president lost
instead of looking at the election
results from 2020 and saying
they need new ideas or better ideas to
win more votes
the former president
and his supporters have decided the only
way for them to win
is to suppress your vote
and subvert our elections
it's wrong
it's undemocratic
and frankly it's un-american
the second big lie
being told by the former president and
supporters
is that the results of the election of
2020 can't be trusted
the truth is that no election
no election in american history has been
more closely scrutinized
more more carefully counted
every legal challenge questioning the
results
in every court in this country
that could have been made
was made and was rejected
often rejected by republican appointed
judges
including judges appointed by the former
president himself
from state court to the united states
supreme court
recounts were undertaken in state after
state
georgia
georgia counted its results three times
with one recount by hand
phony partisan audits were undertaken
long after the election in several
states
none
changed the results
and in some of them the irony is the
margin of victory actually grew slightly
so let's speak plainly about what
happened in 2020
even before the first ballot was cast
the former president was preemptively so
in doubt about the election results
he built his lie over months
wasn't based on any facts
he was just looking for an excuse a
pretext
to cover for the truth
he's not just a former president
he's a defeated former president
defeated by a margin of over seven
million of your votes
in a full and free and fair election
there is simply zero proof
the election results were inaccurate
in fact in every venue
where evidence had to be produced
an oath to tell the truth had to be
taken
the former president failed to make his
case
just think about this
the former president and supporters
have never been able to explain
how they accept as accurate
the other election results that took
place
on november 3rd
elections for governor
united states senate house of
representatives
elections
which they closed the gap in the house
they challenged none of that president's
name was first
then we went down the line
governors senators house representatives
somehow those results are accurate on
the same ballot
but the presidential race was flawed
and on the same ballot
the same day
cast by the same voters
the only difference
the former president didn't lose those
races
he just lost the one that was his own
finally the third big lie being told by
a former president and supporters
that the mob who sought to impose their
will through violence
are the nation's true patriots
is that what you thought
when you looked at the mob ransacking
the capital
destroying property
literally defecating in the hallways
rifling through the deaths of senators
and representatives
hunting down members of congress
patriots
not my view
to me the true patriots were the more
than 150 americans who peacefully
expressed their vote at the ballot box
the election workers have protected the
integrity of the vote
and the heroes who defended this capital
you can't love your country only when
you win
you can't obey the law only when it's
convenient
you can't be patriotic when you embrace
and enable lies
those who stormed this capital
and those who instigated and incited
and those who called on them to do so
held a dagger at the throat of america
an american democracy
they didn't come here out of patriotism
or principle
they came here in rage
not in service of america
but rather in service of one man
those who incited the mob
the real plotters who were desperate to
deny the certification of this election
defy the will of the voters
but their plot was foiled
congressman democrats republicans stayed
senators representatives staff
they finished their work the
constitution demanded
they honor their oath
to defend the constitution against all
enemies foreign and domestic
look folks
now it's up to all of us
to we the people
to stand for the rule of law
to preserve the flame of democracy
to keep the promise of america alive
the promises at risk
targeted by the forces that value brute
strength
over the sanctity of democracy
fear over hope
personal gain over public good
make no mistake about it
we're living at an inflection point in
history
both at home and abroad
we're engaged anew in a struggle between
democracy and autocracy
between the aspirations of the many
and the greed of the few
between the people's right of
self-determination
and
self-self-seeking autocrat
from china
to russia and beyond
they're betting the democracy's days are
numbered
they've actually told me democracy is
too slow
too bogged down by division
to succeed in today's rapidly changing
complicated world
and they're betting
for betting america will become more
like them
and less like us
forbidden in america is a place for the
autocrat the dictator the strongman
i do not believe that that is not who we
are that is not who we have ever been
and that is not who we should ever ever
be
our founding fathers
as imperfect as they were
set in motion an experiment that changed
the world literally changed the world
here in america
the people would rule
power would be transferred peacefully
never at the tip of a spear or the
barrel of a gun
they committed
paper and idea that couldn't live up to
they couldn't live up to but an idea
that couldn't be constrained
yes in america all people
are created equal
a rejected view
that if you succeed
i fail
if you get ahead
i fall behind
if i hold you down
i somehow lift myself up
former president who lies about this
election
and the mob that attacked this capital
could not be further away
from the core
american values
they want to rule
or they will ruin
ruin what our country fought for it
lexington and concord at gettysburg an
omaha beach
seneca falls
some alabama
what
and what we're fighting for
the right to vote
the right to govern ourselves
right to determine our own destiny
with rights come responsibilities
responsibility to see each other as
neighbors
maybe we disagree with that neighbor but
they're not an adversary
responsibility except defeat
then get back in the arena and try again
the next time to make your case
responsibility to see that america is an
idea
an idea
requires vigilant stewardship
as we stand here today
one year since january 6 2021
the lies that drove the anger and
madness we saw on this place
they have not abated
so we have to be firm
resolute and unyielding in our defense
of the right to vote
and have that vote counted
some have already made the element
sacrifice
in this sacred effort
jill and i
the more police officers in this capital
rotunda not once but twice
in the wake of january 6th wants to
honor officer brian sicknick
who lost his life the day after the
attack and the second time to honor
officer billy evans
who lost his life defending his capital
as well
we think about the others who lost their
lives when were injured and everyone
living with the trauma of that day
from those defending this capital
to members of congress in both parties
and their staffs
to reporters
cafeteria workers custodial workers and
their families
don't kid yourself
the pain and scars from that day run
deep
i've said it many times
and it's no more true or real
when we think about the events of
january 6th
we are
in a battle for the soul of america
a battle
that by the grace of god
and the goodness and gracious
greatness of this nation we will win
believe me
i know how difficult democracy is
i'm crystal clear
about the threats
america faces
but i also know
that our darkest days
can lead to light and hope
from the death and destruction as the
vice president referenced in pearl
harbor
came to triumph over the forces of
fascism
from the brutality of bloody sunday
on the edmund pettus bridge
became historic voting rights
legislation
so now let's step up
write the next chapter in american
history
where january 6 marks not the end of
democracy
but the beginning of a renaissance of
liberty and fair play
i did not seek this fight
brought to this capital one year ago
today
but i will not shrink from it either
i will stand in this breach
i will defend this nation
not allow no one to place a dagger at
the throat of democracy
we will make sure the will of the people
is heard
that the ballot prevails not violence
that authority in this nation will
always
be peacefully transferred
i believe the power of the presidency
and the purpose is to unite this nation
not divide it so lift us up
not tear us apart
it's about us
about us
not about me
deep in the heart of america burns
aflame then almost 250 years ago
of liberty freedom and equality
this is not a land of kings or dictators
or autocrats
we're a nation of laws of order not
chaos of peace not violence
here in america the people rule
through the ballot
and their will prevails
so let us remember together
we're one nation
under god
indivisible
that today
tomorrow
and forever at our best we are the
united states of america
god bless you all
may god protect our troops
and my god
bless those who stand watch over
democracy
sorry yes sir
thank you guys thank you